[Music]
oh well let's check out crypto dire
we've covered this guy before she
changed his name a lot but as soon as
you see the video you're gonna know mike
was asking me before the show how do you
get a girl horny while texting instantly
yeah that's that's what i was i was like
dude i don't know how to do it
well check it out hello guys welcome
back to alpha show a channel that will
turn you into a member alpha show
you don't remember off the show do you
this too he's pivoted he calls himself
crypto diary now listen there's two
things
there's two things
that men who are something don't call
themselves alphas
or highly intelligent
if somebody tells you that somebody if
anyone ever insists that they're an
alpha or that they're super smart or
that they're a really good person
run because they're none of those things
uh frozen you're gonna have to return
that highly intelligent alpha shirt you
got for merch
okay i will no no it's okay cause he got
me one okay that's right it's like a
nickname if he gives me one then it's
cool
[Laughter]
i want to go to the gym in a shirt that
just says alpha male with my body and
then just
like next to all these what next to all
these dudes that are just jacked oh yeah
it's a good point i'm giving people a
chance to grab a pen here so you know
how to get to make her a horny instantly
gym wearing an alpha shirt and pushing
around guys that are like six three
three hundred pounds hey
that's my lat pull down machine
beat it
first off sir this is the thigh press so
you're the wrong machine you know what
would happen right the large gentleman
would politely walk away from the
machine
and then i would start doing lap pull
downs and two minutes later somebody
from the gym would come over and go
we've terminated your membership get out
and also we're still charging on pizza
friday
i don't go to planetfit on pizza friday
not on pizza party fridays
who are these podcasts in the chat
what's up
have you heard of these guys who are
these podcasts uh i heard
i've been doing this since i was 18. he
says i'm a super smart alpha carl says
uh let's see here
alpha in today's video i'll teach you
guys a very very powerful technique of
texting that will make any girl crazy
wet and horny just by reading but
unfortunately then she's going to hear
your goofy voice and her [ __ ] will dry
up faster than the sahara leave bali
song alone
i it look bailly song is the [ __ ]
smoothest operator on the planet
compared to this point
in your texts so if you're ready to
become master of getting girls horny
make sure the [ __ ] you want to make
girls horny bro
let's make it them horny they will send
those pictures of their [ __ ] frozen
are you writing this down
by the way
one of my favorite royce things that he
always does is
is frozen are you writing this down it
always gets right
frozen you got a pen and paper write
this down please
thanks for the next steps on how to do
just that before i just want to quickly
mention our 30-day blueprint to becoming
complete alpha male if you are
interested can i see what you look like
sir
no
first link in the description okay
so let's get one thing straight first he
sounds like a polish goofy
girls
are sexual creatures girls love sex
girls think about sex maybe even more
than you do girls women whatever you
want to refer to i refer to them as
women because i'm not a pedophile but i
guess you could do it marla says this
has to be a troll no it's not we've
covered this guys this guy's legit
they're sex as they are not this guy
ever shown himself no not not that i've
seen frozen the [ __ ] balls on it say
what you want about tusk and [ __ ]
francis all these other oh yeah we
[ __ ] trolled them friday but all
these other [ __ ]
it's like at least
they show themselves right like this guy
doesn't even do that much
so i kind of deep dived on his videos
yeah there's two voices either you get
this voice
or like a robotic british voice yeah
we've got in that one too
uh something that to point out guys and
just to tell you when we were bored
after uh thursday's show
we were all just kind of hanging out and
it was
me marsh frozen and pessy pessi hopped
into the voice chat and we were just
happy to be just farting around and tusk
one of the pickup artists went live with
his buddy
and the four of us just us
just us for completely shut down his
live stream for just for it we didn't
even tweet it out no it was just us
[ __ ] around yeah
it was just completely he was so angry
merch kept going it's like hey man has
really come to crush puss like is this
where i do it bro oh yeah i was pointing
out that they were all sex tourists yeah
i was like how is how is hiring
prostitutes in third world countries
make you a [ __ ] chad
and then royce kept pointing out his
[ __ ] hey uh where do you get your
fake watches because i noticed they fog
up in the pool excuse me i call them
timepieces oh he goes yeah where's you
get those fake timepieces because uh
real ones don't [ __ ] up in the pool and
the guy was like oh no oh no this is
real this is real and then i'm like
that's [ __ ] the most expensive watch
i've ever owned is a shitty 500 invicta
watch and it's never fogged up in a pool
oh [ __ ]
we were bored poor creatures
francis oh god that's true
you guys are nothing compared to frank
francis jose francis is a real alpha
he's like yeah dude you guys should
really learn a thing or two
[Laughter]
hang on i want to learn how to make the
girls horny okay you want to learn we
got this make them out to be i hope you
already knew this but i had to make sure
it's not the accent because the accent
whatever but it's just
he sounds like a [ __ ] character an
american dad yeah oh
he does yes
sure we are on the same page and since
you already know this you should also
know that every girl enjoys a bit of
sexting from time to time especially
while she's ovulating
see this is guys
get your k frozen frozen write down the
ovulation schedule this is above you
gentlemen
okay thank you gentlemen
man if you're watching this
glasses off i i need to talk to you
you should never know or care about when
a woman's ovulating unless you're
married unless you're trying to get
pregnant and you're trying to get
pregnant and me and even then
only if you're maybe having some
difficulties doing it right because most
people it's like yeah we decided to get
pregnant so i nutted in my wife and we
had a baby some people that have trouble
they'll start going i was attributed to
michael malus
i was
like michael
michael malus once said me and my wife
i'm gonna nut in my wife
i'm gonna go grab one of those little
one of those little step stools you see
at the library
climb up on there mount my wife later
michael malus no but like
no guys you should let me tell you
something you want to watch
run faster than [ __ ] the roadrunner
away from you bring up ovulating they
love dude let me ask you a question
because mike because then now i'm a
little confused
i shouldn't cha like frozen single right
obviously
um
frozen
wait a second frozen i'm helping you out
here frozen shouldn't chase women with
their ovulation schedule on a notebook
you shouldn't have a chart with eggs
drawn on it on a [ __ ] and a calendar
all right good but like this is
literally like guys i want to say this
point to a calendar and say when pokemon
no please don't do that
listen guys if you're looking at women
at like a starbucks right and you're
going should i go talk to her and you
start going okay she's
it's a white girl
time's at by
seems to be ovulating
um
it's okay well socioeconomics
you have a
37.6 chance of getting a pause if you're
thinking like that
you're not ready to talk to women stop
it now imagine everything you just said
and then walking i'm going hello i think
you are obviously
hello are your eggs recycling inside of
your body if so i would like to sext
with you on the telephone i recently
purchased i recently purchased this
hawaii smartphone and i would like to
text you on it maybe for you to send me
[ __ ] pictures on
no
it's biology before we continue for
those that don't know what sexting means
sexting is basically by the way i just
want to point out you know i got this
chick's number a couple weeks ago all
right so is she ovulating she was
ovulating okay good there's a buddy of
mine that i ran into at the same bar
it's ibor you know
i ran into an old buddy of mine and we
were catching up and having some drinks
whatever we're getting rowdy and
he was just hitting on this chick
nonstop and it was like
he was just so winging and missing and
uh swinging and missing and it was funny
so i finally she finally like firmly
shot him down in front of me and you
know how it is when you're boys with
somebody you cannot you have to be like
oh god
and i was like holding my heart making
fun of him and i was goofing on him the
whole time and then he ended up having
to leave because you know whatever
he wasn't like
but it was like we hung out a little
while longer and then he's like i got it
i gotta get out of here i'm like oh i
get it man so as he was leaving whatever
uh the chick came over whatever to talk
or whatever and then he was like and i i
jokingly was like hey when are you gonna
call me because he pulled out that move
at one point and she's like oh yeah give
me your phone and i was like oh
i was half kidding and i'm like yeah all
right here and i just get she's like
oh yeah just give me a call and i'm like
oh okay see how he's doing i don't know
who's ovulating i didn't calculate it it
was literally
accidentally just making fun of somebody
and then going yeah you want to hang out
sometime here's my number
there you go i'm like oh oh here's
another michael malus quote
i support gay marriage as long as you're
the same race
that's not that was michael malus no
[ __ ] was that really him there is
something funny about i support gay
marriage as long as they're the same
race it's hilarious
let's start doing fake michael malus
quotes next thing before i teach you how
to master getting girls horny over
texting i want to let you know about few
potential problems of why you're not
getting any sex so if you are watching
this video and thinking have they heard
your voice
i wonder why i never get any sex from
girls then you've come to the right
place you're not getting any sex because
you're probably doing one of a few
things wrong
problem number one dude i'm doing
something no you got it
no i am the one who might be doing
something wrong
number one attraction type of guy
you have to make sure they're ovulating
michael malus a lot of michael malone
wow i didn't know that there
libertas says michael malus would love
this bit well he's free to steal it like
he does every other thought that comes
out of his [ __ ] mouth
into you you probably won't be getting
any sex naked pictures or if you're
anything like me you probably will never
be getting sex and that's okay
back to the drawing board
where you will draw literally where you
are drawing pictures of eggs and charts
and moon pictures of moons and eggs
literally if you're figuring out
ovulation if you are seeing her to maybe
have her period during the half moon
then perhaps next month by the quarter
moon she will be ovulating
i'm talking from her but don't worry
i'll teach you how to get her extremely
sexually into you in this video you have
to arouse i want to see what you look
like dude i i don't [ __ ] look man it's a
shallow i want to know what you look
like
i don't think this is going to work for
me i don't think i can recreate this
voice
no you can't just do your chinchong
voice
in order to get dirty texts and photos
from a girl you can't just attract her
she has to act by the way you got to
correct somebody in the chat
girls only ovulate on full moons they're
not werewolves
i know they act like them sometimes
but you're not i don't i think you're
getting women confused
with werewolves that was a michael malus
quote that was it wasn't him oh okay
are you trying to [ __ ] a chick or a
member of the companions
[Laughter]
um
deep inside her before she'll actively
engage you in sexting and problem number
three
you come on man right told you have to
write this down i don't remember ever
being this horny like even as a teenager
i don't remember simply
okay i got it thank you
thank you he's writing it down i just
don't like
i do you even like cause look when we
were young you know young guys i kind of
excuse young guys because
you are just like a breathing machine
for your dick when you're a kid like
you're just running around trying to
[ __ ] [ __ ] i get that
but like
even at my fuckiest
i was never like this dude i who's li
why are people liked it who's saying
things like snip my [ __ ] into her i've
never said that
in my life i've never gone out
like even when i've gone out with
friends and been like yo let's try to
get some you know whatever
if we meet some girls tonight let's try
to get laid like
i don't ever remember sitting with my
boys at a bar and plotting like this and
being like oh yeah i'm going to slip in
my [ __ ] into her like it's this who's
you're not
why are you like this alpha wolf guy
dude deckless thirsty guys you go from
zero to 100 way too quickly instead of
pre-heating oh wow okay piss is stored
in the balls michael malus that's that
was good that was him right prominent
michael malus quote okay i like all
these michael malus quotes keep them
coming okay in the oven you are way too
hungry or thirsty you throw it in on a
broil and forget the omen miss when you
are trying to take it out you have no
patience uh here's another one welcome
the day wave i'm your host royce lopez
michael malus
can we just get our fans to start
attributing quotes to us that aren't
ours like michael mouse
michael malus fans are all [ __ ]
smooth brains
women love man of faction they love men
who go after another thing temple only
has michael malus on his show because
he's the only man in the e-celeb sphere
who can physically overpower that's true
that's a true story that's actually a
quote from michael miller it's actually
cool
[Laughter]
but only if done in the proper manner
always be a gentleman you shouldn't ever
come off as a brazen or rude social
with no filter for example this is an
awful text to send to a girl oh okay
this is a bad section bad one it's
meeting you last night can't wait to
[ __ ] you sideways later this week
there's no banter there's no flirting
there is no sizzle you seem thirsty this
girl will lose the attraction
uh it's this restaurant they used to
have a salad bar and steaks they shut
down and actually wrong depending on by
the way that is a [ __ ]
bold hail mary
that will very likely not work
but again these
guys they put women into this box and
then they go
okay all women will either react
positively or negatively to this but
what they what none of these [ __ ]
pick
pickup
wolf alpha weirdos will ever tell you
is that every woman is different and and
it's
it's any human being you meet
you can take people and break them down
into categories of people
and have some
luck depending on what you've once
you've felt them out a little bit you
can kind of okay or felt them up ah
classic michael mouse oh you put your
[ __ ] into their [ __ ]
you but like you can
whatever you can feel people out
whatever
but believe it or not what he just said
there with the right chick
at the right time if she's in the right
mood would absolutely work i had a buddy
remember terry mcneilly of course
remember
tv police i see him all the time on
facebook
[Laughter]
you don't see him on tvs nobody watches
the blacklist uh but i have this buddy
terry mcdean who i've known for the eons
and royce has known him for years too
and he's a stand-up comic and whatever
well he um we were at doing a show this
had to be like 10 years ago
and we were at a bar
uh the village pub on long island doing
a comedy show and we got there early and
we were just having drinks it was me him
george gallo a bunch of comics and we're
just drinking and hanging out and these
girls come in
and i watched terry mcneely go up to one
of these chicks and go hey what's going
on i just want to introduce myself could
you guys give them a round of drinks
i just want to let you know how you know
my name is terry mcnealy and i'm just
going to be over here hanging out with
my buddies whenever you're ready to make
out and he walked away and i was like we
were laughing we were just laying like
all right that's pretty funny whatever
but before he even got on stage that
night they were making out he was
literally making out with this trick and
i was like see if you do it right and
you kind of
just busting your child you can do that
this guy's totally wrong
for you if any at all she will think you
think she is a [ __ ] and ignore you okay
guys so these were the two most common
problems of men trying to sext but now
let me teach you how to talk dirty to
girls
get them yourself
here we go hopefully get some sexy shots
be playful tactful but slow down until
you know her now we talked about being
thirsty and using tech to get her warmed
up you can throw all that out of the
window once you know a girl everything
is situational and once you know a girl
you can get away with a lot more than
with the girl you don't know too well
there is a fine line with slowly done
thought you don't want to for example
does this rag smell like chloroform
michael malus that's another michael
bell scout
this is this is so wrong all of this is
so wrong and also by the way you know
here's a thought if you're
and you're weird and you follow these
kind of guys you hear that you hear that
frozen
you can do this in the end this is this
is a wild like i'm about to give you
guys advanced pro gamer moves when it
comes to women did you know that you
could just talk to them like a normal
human being
for a little while
like
here's them like a normal human being
there you go here's the beauty of the
smartphone age is that you could go out
and you could get a hundred numbers from
a hundred
and a hundred you don't know about the
other ones right
and then you can just talk to a bunch of
them
normally
and after a little bit of time has
passed
you'll get one of them at least to [ __ ]
you it's not
difficult like just
just talk like a person
like a person
listen write down don't talk like a
pirate and i don't mean to talk like a
pirate i don't i don't mean like these
[ __ ] um
these pickup artists that just go all
right here's what you got you got to
pretend like you're interested in their
lives like you're not just trying to
stick your dick in them so
bombard them with questions like their
trump in the press [ __ ] in the white
house press room when he was president
bombard them what do you do for a living
when we were born what are your parents
like what's your nationality what are
you doing so what are you doing around
here what are you doing later what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing what are you doing they're
going ah
you can just engage in a normal instead
of going i must see sexy titties in my
inbox and put slipping my [ __ ] into her
vagina
what if you just talk to him
i
trust me most of the women like i look
i've
[ __ ] some monsters in my day you know
whatever but i've i've had a few women
that were way out of my league and every
single one of them
were women that i saw myself having no
shot with
but that were talking to me for some
reason
and since i didn't see it as like a oh
man i'm totally gonna bag this
uh i just was talking to them and being
funny and then they were like you know
you want to grab some drinks one day and
you're like yeah it's i'm down whatever
just be down for whatever and talk to
people like normal humans you'll get
laid accidentally it's insane remember
the [ __ ] israeli she had to beg me
she had to beg me to sleep with her
because i wasn't getting it because she
was
she was pretty hot awful person very hot
she was hot very hot so terrible and she
also had a boyfriend who was mad rich
and i didn't even have a car then so i
was like there's no way this girl wants
to [ __ ] me
and i dude she laid down a few hints
that i never picked up
until one night i think she gave me a
ride home or whatever and we got to my
apartment and then she was like um
i was like all right you know see you
later i'll see you tomorrow whatever
and she literally sighed and was like if
you do not invite me into your home this
time i am [ __ ]
never going to try again and i was like
oh
did you want to come inside it's one of
those like but again we were just pals
and then i was like dude just
just be not weird
just be not weird
[ __ ]